Joe garbar of MSNBC believes that the
reason that Trump doesn't want to show
up to the debate is because he is afraid
of the Chriss asson I do think he's
scared of Chris Christie he saw what
Chris Christie did to Marco Rubio when
Chris Christie went into a baate with
one thing in
mind he knows Chris Christie put Jared
kushner's father in jail for a very long
time he knows he's a prosecutor who's
ruthless and knows how how to to push
his case Chris Christie is not to be
slept on that guy could get a Zinger in
there on Trump maybe maybe let's say the
risk is only 10% if you're Trump and
you're up by 37 points why why would you
take that 10% risk when you have very
little to gain and a lot to lose and
frankly you could even gain more if you
can convince voters that the reason
you're not showing up to the debate is
because the RNC is rigging it against
you